President George weer casts his ballot
hoping it will keep him in office for
another six years but he must beat this
man former Vice President Joseph boakai
his former deputy to Africa's first
female president Liberia struggling with
high unemployment poor infrastructure
and government corruption many people
hope the election would lead to new
investment in the country but many also
fear of violence could break out across
the country after the vote political
figures and other African states share
their concerns there's one thing they
don't need is violence liberians know
that the atrocities of war and conflict
their very possibility of
succeeding as a nation voting began on
time and was largely peaceful in many
areas but attempts to influence the vote
have been recorded in some voters in
Liberia say it's incidents like this
along with the violence that
characterized the first round that give
them a lot of worry low turnout has been
reported in many areas officials expect
results in a few days but it could take
up to 15 before the Electoral commission
announces a winner Ahmed rris Al jazer